this is evidence beginning of the
lecture but how do courage morality grow
from who's stronger and compared to
what's good and what is it well I think
it depends to some degree on what you
mean by stronger so physical strength is
one element and like if you look at
mythological heroes imagine that the
stories of heroes are fragmented
elements of the archetype and so one
kind of archetypal hero obviously is
someone who's physically strong you know
you see that there's a great movie that
you could watch about this it's called
Hitman Hart it's one of the best
documentaries I've ever seen and it's
about this guy named Bret Hart and Bret
Hart was for awhile the most famous
Canadian on the planet and he was a
world wide wrestling foundation I think
what does he call it WWF yeah he was
there like lead good guy and so he and
wrestler I loved the documentary because
when I was a little kid like four or
five I used to watch his father whose
name was Stu Hart who ran this channel
this wrestling Confederation in Alberta
and Stu Hart had I think eight boys and
he trained all of them to be pro
wrestlers and part of the movie is
extraordinarily funny because Stu Hart
is in it and he's really old
he's like 85 and he's just barely
imagined he was like a pro wrestler for
four years like every joint is broken
and he's still big but he's just barely
moving and this is kid and another kid
come over and Stu is telling the story
about how he used to take his boys into
the basement and toughen them up and I
think Brett called that the journey to
pain or something like that his father
would take all these kids down there
wrestle with them and push them right to
the edge of their pain tolerance
constantly and so and anyway they grew
up top there's no doubt about that and
all his daughters married pro wrestlers
too and I think he had seven daughters
so he's quite the character anyways
these two kids they're like they're late
adolescence early adulthood come over
and one of them is pretty damn cocky and
he's listening to Stuart he says
something smart like well you know you
were pretty you're pretty tough with the
old days hey
and Stu looks at them and says well why
don't you come down to the basement with
me and and he says look I don't want to
hurt you old man and so so the
filmmakers follow them into the basement
day and and like they're they're kind of
standing there and they're all guy grabs
him in a headlock and takes him like
he's like a snake hey you got her in a
headlock like so fast that that kid
doesn't know what to do and so still I
he knows how to put a headlock on
someone he's like flexing is his uh his
uh his forearm yeah which is flexed oh
not so bad a forearm and he's got this
guy's face it's just he's just he's like
he's stepped in a bear trap plus he's
absolutely shocked that this old guy got
him and so he's kind of gasping and Stu
says something like you watch if I flex
this muscle just right you can see this
vein on his forehead and start to talk
about it's extraordinarily funny twenty
ways Bret Hart plays out the good guy
archetype and and Brett's like he's a
solid guy but he would say he's not
particularly sophisticated and I'm not
not being cruel about that I mean he had
a great career and he's tough as a boot
and so good for him but he plays out
this this good guy archetype and he gets
tangled up in it and now I don't
remember your damn question but I am
trying to answer it look tell me the
question again Sally Mally you go from
you strongest vegans to look good and
with oh yes yes okay exactly well so one
of the things I really liked about this
movie was it showed me why people watch
wrestling and I couldn't I could because
certainly they're not appealing and I'm
not being there are different strata of
conception of abstraction that any
entertainment process has to appeal to
and you know most people don't go to
movies and that's actually because it
really is because movies operate at a
level of sophistication that are too hot
that is too high for many people just
like novels I mean hardly anyone reads
you know and if you about 15% of the
population might be twenty percent
cannot read well enough to follow in
written instructions and so and they and
people who are maybe it's 15% of the
population or ten percent have never
finished a book never and so and it is
that
I but but you still there still the
archetype still needs to manifest itself
at different levels and so it manifests
itself in wrestling but even there where
it is physical force it's not just
physical force like it's a drama between
good and evil and you can see this so
clearly and then in the Bret Hart
documentary because he's the good guy
and no the bad guys are really over the
top bad it's a real drama it's like it's
good versus evil in the ring every time
and hopefully good wins but good often
gets you know maybe the bad wrestler
brings two of his friends in and they
bring in chairs and they bash the hell
out of the good guy it the whole
audience is just outraged by this and
and the documentary does a lovely job of
showing that but so even at the level of
physical combat let's say you can't
reduce what's good - what's strong it's
just one element of it better to be
strong than to be weak and so you can
have a strong hero because it's better
to be strong than to be weak but it's
better to be strong and kind than to be
strong and it's better to be strong and
kind and wise than to be strong and kind
and so and that's true not only for
human beings but it's even true let's
say at the wolf or the chimpanzee level
because one of the things you see with
the chimp dominance hierarchies if and I
think I mentioned this before is if the
leader the dominant male is really good
at fostering social relations and being
reciprocal and acts like grooming and
also paying attention to the females and
their offspring his dynasty will be much
more stable and so strong might be good
for one battle it might be good for two
battles but for 50 battles it's not
optimized especially because no law no
matter how strong you are someone can
take you out so so what happens is the
idea of what's ideal becomes
increasingly complex across time
multifaceted right and so strength
wisdom intelligence vision all these
things are amalgamated into a single
being and we'll talk a lot about that
because I want to show you how that
happened in Mesopotamia because that's
one of the first places where we have
documentation about how that ideal
emerged they have a god called Marduk
and Marduk had fifty names
and as far as I can tell the reason for
that was that Marduk was an amalgam of
the tribal deities of at least 50 tribes
and and when the tribes were brought
together and civilized each of their
gods who were ideals had to be
amalgamated into something that was a
single a single dramatized
representation of value or there was no
way that all those people could live
together right their different value
structures would have fragmented them
and they would have stated in a state of
war and so the question is it's the
question you're asking if it's not
strength then what is it well strength
is an element but the Egyptians figured
out that it was vision was actually the
capacity to pay attention that was
paramount and the Mesopotamians had that
figured out more or less - because their
God Marduk had eyes all the way around
his head he could see everywhere so
seeing was a critical element of what
should be on top and the other thing for
the Mesopotamians was the ability to
speak so by the time of Mesopotamia
people had already dramatized the idea
that that Cardinal human attributes are
vision and the ability to speak so and
that be the ability to speak the truth
to not just speak so